[музика]
Привіт друзі і дорослі і малеча з вами я
пані Ліда і мій друг ведмежатко бо
привіт
[музика]
ми далі рухаємося з вами по абетці і
сьогодні у нас знову дуже цікава літера
і називається вона літера і
звук і
ось послухайте про неї віршик гей
хлопчику йони хлопчик гей стовпчику я не
стовпчик хто ж ти такий
буква і
А що в тебе на голові
шапка Ні
крапка Подивіться будь ласка ось у нас
літера і
і велика і маленька і над маленькою
літерою справді ніби шапочка але це не
шапка а крапка бачите Яка цікава літера
і вона дуже простенька у написанні адже
вона просто як стовпчик Якщо ми візьмемо
з вами Ось цей олівчик він може нагадати
нам літеру і правда ведмедику тук-тук
дуже просто беремо і пишемо приготуємо
собі пальчик і напишемо літеру і
намалюємо ось такий стовпчик
як олівчик
так друзі молодці а зараз послухайте які
є слова на літеру і і іграшка
і
ірис ірис - це така квітка красива і
дуже духмяна
і
ігуана
ведмедику Чи знаєш ти хто така ігуана Ні
я такого не чув ніколи і не бачив
ігуана друзі це така ящірка
і інжир
інжир друзі це таке плодове дерево дуже
корисні його плоди і ікра і круг
відкладають рибки абуть ви вже знаєте
Пізнай маленькі рибки виростають
і
іглу чи знаєте ви що таке іглу це таке
житло ескімосів народ який живе на
півночі нашої землі
вони будують його
і воно навіть влітку не Тане це їх житло
уявляєте Як цікаво гаразд А ось тут у
нас ще є слова на літеру і
індик
іній
іній такий буває взимку на деревах
Бачите як він красиво лягає на гілочки
Іскра
іскра з вогню буває так гаразд А ще є
імена на літеру і
Пригадайте дітки які ви знаєте імена на
літеру і
можливо серед ваших друзів є друзі імена
яких починаються з літери і
і Іванко
і Іринка
і Інна
і Ілля
[музика]
ось такі є імена гаразд А зараз я
пропоную вам відгадати загадки ось
послухайте
надувається ґелґоче наче щось сказати
хоче
бігає туди-сюди краще його Обійди хто це
такий Як ви думаєте
підказка є у нас на дошці
Він має красивий хвостик як у павича він
так роздуває цей хвостик красиво але
краще цих птахів обходити вони можуть
бути трішки небезпечними
так друзі вірно це індик Ось він в нас
на малюночку індик вірно молодці а зараз
Давайте ми з вами складемо слово індик з
наших літер перша літера літера і
наступна
м ще одна літера де
наступна и
остання літера літера к
і ми зможемо прочитати всі літери разом
ведмедику Давай спробуємо
[музика]
дик індик вірно ми написали слово індик
ну а зараз час на гру Приготуйте свої
долоньки розімніть пальчики зробимо 1 2
3 4 5 вийшли пальці погулять Давайте
зробимо ліхтарики ліхтарики світяться і
закрилися світяться і закрилися і ще
порухаємо пальчиками пальчики наші
готові долоньки готові Ми з ведмедиком
говоримо слово а ви плескаєте у долоні
коли почуєте у цих словах літеру і
пам'ятаєте як вона і виглядає і
промовляється звук І це звук голосний ми
говоримо його без перешкод давайте
промовимо з вами разом
і ведмедику тепер ти
молодець ведмедик супер- тобі вдається
справді ми можемо проспівати цілу
пісеньку на цей звук а зараз час на гру
Нумо побавимось
Отже будьте уважні так перше слово
долоньки вже готові кінь
плескаємо молодці
носоріг
[музика]
і в цьому слові є літера і звук і
плескаємо знову супер
сонце
неплескаємо немає цієї літери
і глу
такий будиночок пригадуєте зі снігом Так
є літера і ми про нього вже говорили
сьогодні пінгвін
в цьому слові навіть дві літери і супер
молодці і я чую що виплеснули Гаразд
стіл
так плескаємо супер палець
не плескаємо немає там літери і звука і
малюнок
немає І ще одне слово іграшка
супер молодці у слові іграшка на початку
слова якраз і є літера і Ну що ж
а зараз час почитати нам склади з
буквочками які ми вже з вами вивчили так
літеру і ми залишимо на дошці
і будемо добавляти до неї різні
приголосні літери приголосні Пригадайте
ми вимовляємо з перешкодою голосні без
перешкоди ось приголосна
б і голосна і ведмедику прочитай що
вийшло
бі молодець супер поміняємо приголосну
так друзі ваша черга Прочитайте будь
ласка склад
ведмедику
ві Ого молодчина ведмедик як ти швидко
навчаєшся гарно і знову поміняємо
приголосне
прошу
її Ого
Молодчинка ось ми з вами навчилися
читати літеру і разом з приголосною
навчилися розгадувати загадки і
послухали віршик про літеру і
А зараз домашнє завдання
Пригадайте у яких словах сьогодні на
занятті ви почули літеру і звук і
навчіться її вдома писати
і відшукайте її у своїх улюблених
книжечках А ми з ведмедиком будемо з
вами прощатися Дякуємо вам друзі за
перегляд і до нових зустрічей па-па
[музика]
Привіт Привіт друзі з вами пані Настя і
час трошечки порухатись і розрухати своє
тіло станьте будь ласка в зручне для вас
місце там де навколо Немає нічого
зайвого
випрямте ніжки
випрямте вашу спинку розправте плечики
супер
ми починаємо з того що ставимо ручки Ось
так собі на пояс і нахиляємо в голову
вправо і вліво вправо і вліво
добре а тепер вперед і назад вперед і
назад
Окей і по колу
і в іншу сторону
Окей добре Тепер Ми піднімаємо плечики
Вверх і скидаємо вниз ще Вверх і скинули
вниз і
добре а тепер по черзі одне Вверх і інше
одне і поміняли і трошечки швидше
[музика]
Добре тепер робимо вдих
і видих і ще вдих
і видих чудово ставимо ручки на пояс
нахиляємось вправо
і вліво
можна поставити ніжки трошки ширше
вправо
і вліво і ще вправо і вліво тепер перед
і трошечки назад
і назад і ще вперед і назад чудово тепер
ми з вами переходимо на підлогу
Сідаємо Ось так ніжки перед нами ручки
можна поставити біля себе і тепер будемо
піднімати наші ніжки вправо і ліво так і
ще трошки
добре порухали Трошки ніжками А тепер
будемо робити такий Човник ми трошечки
відхиляємось назад і піднімаємо наші
ніжки і ручки вперед
чудово тримаємо 1 2 3 4 5 опустили добре
можете обняти свої ніжки поставити їх
трошки ближче
добре І давайте ще раз так зробимо і
потримаємо 5 секунд Добре давайте
приготувалися і
відхиляємось трошечки назад але не
провалюємось Ось так тримаємо нашу
спинку рівно тягнемо грудну клітину
вперед Окей готові раз два три
піднімаємо Окей і ручки вперед сидимо в
човнику рахуємо один два три чотири
п'ять
опустили ніжки добре обійміть свої ніжки
Чудово Ну а тепер нам потрібно лягти на
животик лягаємо на животик і будемо
робити таку вправу дельфінчик ми ручки
витягуємо вперед і зараз будемо
піднімати їх на гору і опускати але
робимо це повільно і Вверх і опускаємо
вниз і ще Вверх
Давайте зробимо ще три рази Один
опустили
два
опустили три
опустили Чудово А тепер
потягнемось трошечки назад
чудово і подивіться
назад
і опускаємось
і ще один раз піднімаємось вгору
виштовхуємо тут плечики не провалюємось
Ось так а намагаємось показати свою
довгу шику покажіть мені свою довгошико
так чудово і
опускаємось вниз Сідаємо на п'яточки
трошки потягніть спинку
є Чудово Ну а тепер ми знов переходимо
на животик будемо робити корзинку беремо
свої ніжки ось тут опускаємо поки що
голову і зараз ми будемо піднімати
голову і ніжки вверх Давайте спробуємо
робимо корзинку один два три піднімаємо
і тримаємось
давайте порахуємо до трьох один
два три і опустили чудово можна
поставити ручки одна на одну і опустити
нашу чуло
і давайте ще раз зробимо цю корзинку
беремо себе за ніжки і піднімаємось
вверх тримаємо чудова корзинка один
два
3 трошки довше потримаємо 4 5 чудо і
опускаємось
супер ми з вами сьогодні
розм'яли спинку Я сподіваюся що ви
почуваєте себе бадьорами і сильними
молодці Ви чудово порухались па-па
[музика]